Sonia Samagh, MBA 2011: "My name is Sonia
Samagh, and I am a student here at the GSB.
I've completed three years of Medical school
and I'm here at the GSB to complete two years
of my MBA. My interest in medicine stems from
the values that my parents instilled within
me. As a member of the Sikh faith, the idea
of Seva and selfless service drew me towards
a profession like medicine.
My interest in global health was really sparked
by this idea of health and innovation. I teamed
up with the professor who led the course.
Essentially what he did is he brought in surgeons
from around the world to tell us about all
the amazing things that they were doing, either
leper colonies in India or cataract surgery
in Africa...and I thought to myself "this
is something I absolutely want to do, too."
And so he and I organized our first trip to
Mexico, where we helped another group of surgeons
treat cleft lip and palate and burn victims.
With this professor, I started the non-profit
Global Health Volunteers.
In founding Global Health Volunteers and going
to medical school, I've realized that my long-term
goal is to become CEO of a non-profit in international
health and medicine. In order to run an organization
effectively, I needed a tool set to do so...more
importantly a business school tool set that
the Stanford GSB in particular cultivates
in its leaders. We're on the campus that has
so many different disciplines, so for me coming
in as a MD/MBA student there are a lot of
opportunities to combine my medicine background
and a new business skill set. The motto of
the Stanford Business School is "change lives,
change organizations, change the world." And
I realized that that's what I wanted to do
with Global Health Volunteers and coming to
Stanford will really give me the toolkit to
be able to become an effective leader. To
create an organization that really did change
lives, and change the world in the area of
international health and medicine."